you mentioned body comp
you said you can answer that one easily
uh do you share your body count do you
know your body count do you know is
there a spreadsheet there's a
spreadsheet yes there's a Google Sheets
is it Excel sheets yeah okay have you
run like uh is there
you don't have to share the the the
contents but is there like data on each
so I track uh paid clients and free sex
separately and I attract different
things on either like with clients I
track like positions we used and who had
an orgasm and with personal people I
just track basically like age City
you know name and I I I've had things
like 42 people I think for free so it's
I'm sharing this because like I want
people to calibrate like it's not like
huge it's not like tiny one of the
people I've recently talked to uh Mel
Destiny's
Stephen's uh wife is a huge fan of yours
uh she was actually really excited to
get to uh talk to you but she I think
she said her body count is more than 42
I think she said 60. something like this
and so
it's interesting because she was like
saying like she loves like looking at
your at your work talking to you
because you have similar perspectives on
the world and it's really refreshing
it's liberating
wow oh it's really sweet it's kind of
interesting yeah so what is there like
an optimal body comp like if you were to
map I wonder yeah what have you found
out about body count and doing have you
actually done surveys on body count like
on how many people
selected that information on my last
survey I just haven't looked at it yet
things to look at so I haven't yeah but
I think if I'm sleeping with a guy and
he's had sex with more than 120 people
then I start to get a little bit wary
well 120 is opposed to 100 I don't know
I just like kind of skimmed through the
numbers in my head and picked one that
felt right just know yeah 120 ish I
think that's why I'm starting like so
you're flexible yeah
[Laughter]
um but 200 is a hard line for sure well
it's you know you have to it depends the
factors because like there's a there's a
level of body count at which you start
to wonder if how much
like accidental misrepresentation a guy
is doing to you
oh like if if you're saying 200 that
might be dishonest no like if he's had
sex with 200 girls uh this means that
he's had a lot of casual sex
um and not a lot of like long-term
relationships assuming that he's you
know hasn't been super poly yeah and
this usually means that there has to be
some sort of
um like indication that he cares about
the girl more than he actually does
like he oh because he's like leading you
on basically
um and so I'm not saying this is
necessarily the case I'm saying like at
a certain level of number I start to
become I start to wonder if this is
what's happening is there like from your
understanding of it is there a different
perception between men and women like if
you look at the high body count for a
woman versus a high body count for a man
like how's Society views it oh yeah
people are way more judgmental of women
uh I haven't experienced this personally
in my circles because I'm in very
sex-friendly circles like I'm in orgy
circles where everybody like dates the
same women and they're like woo good job
uh but yeah people are much more like
people always tell me online like you're
not ever going to be able to find a
husband because you have sex with too
many people
okay very common which I don't think I
mean like men are also perceived
negatively if you have high body count
but I think I don't think it's
negatively in the same way yeah do you
think it's unethical to lie about in
your body count
yes so all lying is unethical yeah
I'm not a big fan of lying in general
yeah yeah that's interesting bodycon is
an interesting one it's so silly to take
that to care about that but so we do
yeah jealousy is silly but still we get
jealous is that weird
I it's like the thing is like I don't
like viewing emotions as
like irrational even if they are it's
like emotions are always there for a
reason and people don't like high body
counts for a reason too it's just fine
and valid yeah it also is like
yeah I don't know what I make of just
the past of like time
you know like
like each human is a collection of
experiences
and you don't know most of those
experiences and all of a sudden you meet
this bag of experiences
and like what are you supposed to do
with both of your like training data
are you supposed to like like what
like I don't know if we like part of me
wants to not actually ever talk about it
to care at all like why does it matter
because only like the future is that
matters and yet the past also matters a
lot potentially but maybe not really
because you're you're you're somehow
like
constructed from that past but you're no
longer that past
like you're evaluating for something
different
what do you mean like
the reason I'm just talking out my ass
but yes go ahead yeah I'm just saying
crazy [__] like as if I'm on drugs like
kind of sound I think this is like kind
of like lining up with like this this
caricature that I'm building a few based
on this conversation so far great but uh
like a lot of people want to know about
your past because they want to know how
useful and compatible you are with them
like oh do you have a similar job you
know you have a similar culture like
what can I expect from you in the future
like it's very practically oriented
whereas like if the thing that you're
focused on is not like being able to
predict someone
like if the thing that you focus on is
the present moment then it doesn't
really matter anymore they're
they're the things that like their
training data but I also I also think
like the past is not that predictive of
the future is it not not if you believe
in the power of the interaction between
two humans it's like nature versus
nurture I I guess also I don't believe
in the in the if in the ability of
people to accurately describe their own
past this is true because they have a
very specific lens through it that
doesn't necessarily like it's too biased
I can also interpret based on the bias
like if somebody describes their own
past you can kind of pick up like hard
it's difficult like you would you could
if you're a therapist like if you're
really drilling like or whatever sorry
if you're really investigating and like
analyzing it but then it's like it's a
different kind of relationship right
isn't that hard though like if I'm with
a guide I'm considering dating him and I
ask like how did your past relationships
end and then if all of them were like
he's like oh she was crazy and my other
one that she went crazy too I'm like
okay like there's a if you're talking
about all of your exes is insane like
but that's an easy level red flag but I
feel like I feel like the more
that the also it's possible they were
crazy he's attracted to crazy people so
like that yeah but but that I would say
that's like easier love easy level Mario
Kart video game versus like Elder ring
like like
I think most most people's past is like
complicated it's a pretty good bird no
you're right I do agree that like
there's a level of obvious obfuscation
wow that um is hard to see through but
this looks a little bit sometimes but I
tend to like went with people I tend to
in general just human interaction I tend
to not talk about their past very much
because it allows you to focus on like I
feel like the past is kind of like
talking about the weather is a crutch
for me personally interesting like as
opposed to exploring the ideas in their
mind yeah I see is it like I I get
really annoyed when people quote
philosophers when they're trying to talk
about philosophy yeah is it like that
a little but that crutch is useful and
it's kind of sexy like it's kind of like
cool like because it's nice to quote
because like because because a good
quote allows you to be cheesier than you
otherwise would be okay well if you're
doing it to be cheesy that's that's fine
not cheesy but not cheese no no but to
be like it allows you to say a simple
profound thing that we're too afraid to
say with our own words so like the
quoting philosophers in that sense yeah
but it is still a crutch yes but I feel
like the past
is more like talking about your dreams
it just is not
it's a crutch that doesn't care it
doesn't empathize with the other
person's experience of the conversation
or the explanations doesn't really
convey the uh they're not involved in
your past yeah so how do you feel about
this conversation or you're asking me
about my past and I talked about my past
a lot
well I'm okay asking about your past
because you've really carefully thought
about that aspect of it and we didn't
really talk about your past outside of
the things you've written about and I've
really thought about I see like there
there's like when most conversations
you'll start talking about past stuff
that's like the stuff that's actually
bothering you you still probably have
not written a blog post about right like
there's there's probably still stuff
like maybe it's it's more recent like
the last few months last couple years
like that's usually what we'll come up
with conversation and just
it's good it's good but it's not as deep
and I would say it's not as intimate as
talking about the actual
ideas in your mind I see and how you
interact with them so like the past is
interesting for the frame of like
sort of like the like I guess you're
right I guess we're talking a lot about
like narrative yeah in past yeah I like
the ideas in people's minds versus their
Recollections and memories and so on
yeah